kind of pile our barnacles up and
get a view over the top of the whale
well in slow motion it's happening uh
like on the internet for example
that what i do
is essentially the kind of con talking
to you about psychedelics is the kind of
conversation that 30 years ago
could only happen among the nearest and
dearest of friends across the kitchen
table
and the news was tremendous almost like
a revelation
for instance i guess one of the things
i'm most well known for is the concept
of self-transforming machine elves
i encountered them in dmt i named them
described them raved about them wouldn't
shut up about them and they but they
have gone from being my private
domain to being a recognized class of
phenomena in fact
self-transforming
machine elves
is now abbreviated as stems
and i noticed uh they're just referred
to this way they broke into crimson
space
several dozen stems present uh process
and it's like so the meme has been
launched um
and we now are having the end of the
world conversation about our gender
identities about our past about our
experiences about the future uh
we we are the image i have is almost of
an aircraft
that is
attempting to redesign itself in flight
you know we're a sop with camel we're a
biplane chugging along but we're
approaching the
sound barrier we have to completely
redesign our airfoil
or the wings are going to be ripped off
and we're going to plunge to the
unfriendly territory below and we do
this by talking to each other and by
leveling with each other and by looking
discovering the nature of our own
psyches and societies and then
attempting to communicate it
could you say something further about
the kind of
slightly sinister nature of the
types
[Music]
it isn't sinister
well perhaps it is let me say how it
appears to me
they're reckless
and their brand of
comedy is a little too much to the marx
brothers end of the spectrum
you know or even further than that it's
the three stooges
too much of the hammer on the head and
the two fingers in the eye trip
you
not that they've ever done anything like
that but they're out their elves their
gnomes
the relationship of human beings to fay
is uncertain
and
sometimes they reassure in dmt i almost
always find them reassuring that their
true kibiri true alchemical children and
i think i've quoted for you
the 54th fragment of heraclitus which
says the aeon is a child at play with
colored balls
but
sometimes
and this has a lot to do with i don't
know the dmt and physiological factors
and this and that sometimes
there's an
angry
insectile
intensity
to what happens
where you just say
wow it's really
it's just
you know i can hear it in these whistles
that's what i was mentioning that
there's a place in there which skilled
people who could sustain it could just
summon this thing right up
so
i don't know sometimes in the hallucine
in the hallucinations you have the
intimation that it's a dimension
that even the mushroom is not fully in
command of
i mean i've had experiences where i felt
that i was appalled and the mushroom as
a was appalled the mushroom and i were
playing under a bush like two children
when suddenly the shadow of something
passed by
and the mushroom said you know let's
just sit very still for a minute
and then this thing to see
it's okay now we can go back to what we
were doing
uh
i don't know
you know whether this is human
psychology we don't know
the ecology of souls we don't know what
goes on in hyperspace we have our
cheerful assurances
but sometimes there seem to be pie
radical beings
that don't hold an allegiance to uh
all of these things this is when you
don't want to bungle your mantras
this is when you want to have a quick on
tot sat ready to
let fly
all of these things work
in that dimension they don't ever seem
to work in any other dimension
but in that dimension they you know
thank god you studied all this tibetan
buddhism and all this malarkey because
now you need it you know
so um
i don't know traders tikes
extraterrestrials i had the feeling that
that it's hard for them to communic i
don't know how clearly we are perceived
my dmt trips got friendlier and
friendlier as i sort of prompted them to
get their act a little more together and
to have a care for what a human being
can put up with
the first dmt trip was absolutely
appalling i mean i felt like the big
people were home
and i had just broken into this place
where these things were turning and
saying
what
is this
you know then the next time they had the
little bassinet and the colored
dancing things and the little toys all
ready but the first time
they were taken by surprise and they
were just you know does anyone have a
fly swatter handy
it was that kind of thing
i don't know you have to have your wits
about you this is no place for people
who are true believers i mean i think
that psychedelic people have to be like
you have to be street smart
that's what i think i bring to this that
many of my professional colleagues who
are you know lettered and so forth and
so on they're not street smart they
don't know how to
cut a deal
at the center of an indian ghetto
surrounded by five million people who if
they knew how much money was on your
body would cut you to pieces in a
fraction of a moment you know
they're they're all in their head it it
helps to be
on your toes
it really repays
real attention not some kind of off in
space attention but this is like trading
with cannibals
you know or trading with an amazonian
tribe it's weirder than that they're
offering something you're trying to get
something you need to bring something
then there's negotiation this is
happening across god knows what kind of
intellectual and dimensional gulfs
so i say you know if you're going to
trade in cyberspace you just have to be
on your toes they're not evil
but they are tricky
mischievous
mercurial their idea of a joke may not
entirely tally with your idea of a joke
last question
one last question here was there any
sense of personalization so that when
you
in them would you recognize one as a
character
that you could come back and say i've
seen you before or were they different
each time
no they're it's hard to describe them
they
i can't say that it's the same ones or
different ones it's the same species
it's a kind of being
they don't have a solid body geometry
they are a hallucination
in a hallucination
they are a part of the hallucination
that has separated itself from the
background of hallucination and has come
forward to chat with you
the whole thing is not even happening in
ordinary space time
uh
they are
um they appear to be hyper dimensional
creatures that's why they're changing so
fast that's the the hyper dimensional
aspect of them they cannot
appear as a solid object in a lower
dimensional space
and of course what they're doing is
urging that you try to create this
visible language
that syntax for them is something beheld
and they make
the imagination
out of sound
they are somehow able to
become what they behold
and they can generate
what they behold so they are like a mind
and a language at the same time you
can't tell is this a mind or is it a
language it seems to be both at once we
have minds we speak languages this thing
doesn't have that relationship to these
things perhaps it's a creature of pure
language well what is that well who
knows
how how do you relate to something which
is made not of molecules but of syntax
is it a poem or is it a person
i mean our categories are just scrambled
so badly that you can't tell agnes from
angus
so how could you tell
you know hyperspatial creatures from the
language that they're speaking
this is the frontier of knowing this is
where
all the exciting work
remains to be done
one more
do you think
as i know you do you see yourself maybe
using psychedelics and coming to a point
where you are psychedelic and would no
longer
need
this kind of access no worse that the
plants themselves has educated you
to a point in the future where you would
no longer need them because you
have activated those
no no because talking about it isn't
being there
you know i think that you
i think that
nothing i've said has been
true to the object
that
these are all lower dimensional slices
there is no end to the program of
elaborating a
a new language for describing this i
can't see how it would ever end
my psychedelic career will end when my
courage fails
but i will never
encompass nor will anybody else
what it is because
you know the nature of tao is infinite
the the depth of dao
is infinite but the courage and the life
of man is finite
it just is inevitably that way a mystery
is not an unsolved problem
a mystery is a mystery
it can it can
eject images of ideas out of itself and
visionary programs for transforming
man or society or technology but the
mystery itself
will remain forever a mystery it has to
descend through so many levels to
communicate with us at all that there is
no possibility
of
meeting with it except in this
quintessential moment wherever it may be
in time
when uh
all
all space condenses into a nutshell
when everything comes together but that
only happens once in the life of the
cosmos
otherwise it is something which we
anticipate
in the imagination
[Music]
you